[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMR AWADALLAH: Hi, I'm Amr.
I lead developer
relations at Google Cloud.
What's developer
relations, you might ask.
We are engineers
who love talking
to people who are hands-on.
That includes developers,
operators, data engineers,
data scientists, any
technical practitioner
who makes the Information
Technology world go round.
We are constantly inspired
by and in awe of what you do.
We succeed by supporting
you along the journey
to modernize your
applications and innovate.
Ever since Google Cloud
started working with you,
we learned a lot
about the challenges
of building and operating
enterprise workloads
while also dealing with
the business imperative
to constantly innovate.
For instance, we
see teams struggling
with these four problem areas.
First, they are
constantly occupied
with lots of non-productive,
repetitive tasks,
and in many cases, reinventing
the wheel for things
that have been figured
out many times over.
Second, the businesses are
afraid of frequently updating
their high-value workloads
due to stability and security
concerns, which significantly
hinders the rate of innovation.
Third, they struggle to keep
up with all the mandates
around compliance, auditing,
security, availability,
you name it.
And fourth, it's
almost impossible
to write applications once,
then have them run anywhere,
whether that be on-premises,
in the cloud, or at Edge.
And as you know,
this isn't about
whether you're in
the cloud or not.
Many of you have made the
transition to the cloud
already, but you still
face these challenges.
We want to help you
significantly accelerate
the speed with which you
solve, create, and innovate.
We do this in three ways.
First, we think it's
important to automate
as much as possible.
This means eliminating
repeatable tasks
in pursuit of important
objectives such as secure
by default,
monitoring by default,
canary testing, and continuous
integration and delivery.
In other words, let's stop
reinventing the wheel.
Second, we want to
increase your productivity.
We know that everyone comes
from different backgrounds
and works in
different environments
with different tools.
We embrace this
diversity by supporting
your favorite open-source
frameworks and enterprise
software applications.
And we do this, as
you'll see in this talk,
not just on the infrastructure
side with efforts
like Kubernetes, but
also for developers
by supporting code editors
like IntelliJ and Visual Studio
Code.
Third, you need
portability options
for where your workloads run.
Our goal is to enable you to
write your applications once,
then have them run
anywhere with minimal
to no code changes while
transparently carrying
over all the
security, governance,
and observability requirements.
To demonstrate how
Google Cloud helps you
with all of this,
my colleagues and I
will highlight the
key parts of a journey
from migration to innovation.
We will use a sample
financial application
that we call Demo Bank, a
traditional two-tier business
application that
simulates a bank.
It's already been migrated
from virtual machines
to containers running
on Google Cloud.
What's next in the modernization
journey for Demo Bank?
Let's talk to my
colleague, Megan,
the Developer Relations Engineer
for Anthos, to find out.
Hi, Megan.
Great to see you.
MEGAN O'KEEFE: Hi, Amr.
AMR AWADALLAH: I heard you run
on coffee, so before you start,
would you like some?
MEGAN O'KEEFE: Absolutely.
AMR AWADALLAH: Here you go.
[VORTEX]
MEGAN O'KEEFE: Thank you.
Let's take a look at
how Demo Bank is running
in containers on Anthos.
I'm starting in the
Google Cloud Console,
where I've deployed the app onto
a Kubernetes Engine cluster.
In my project, I actually
have multiple clusters
running for development,
staging, and production,
plus a cluster running in
AWS, which I've registered
to the Anthos dashboard.
This AWS cluster is running
some legacy workloads
that we're trying to
migrate into Google,
but for now we can see
the status of that cluster
in the Anthos dashboard.
Let's take a look at
the production cluster
to see what's running.
Demo Bank is a two-tier web
app with a frontend and two
backends.
One backend is written in
Python, the other in Java.
The backends are monolithic,
each with an embedded SQL
database.
As someone who works with
platform administrators a lot,
something I really
like about Anthos
is the observability you
get right out of the box.
Let's navigate to Anthos
Service Mesh to check it out.
When I migrated Demo Bank from
virtual machines to containers
running on Anthos, each
workload here-- the frontend,
the account service--
has Anthos Service Mesh enabled.
A service mesh tracks
all the requests
flowing through the app
and generates metrics
like requests
throughput and latency.
I didn't have to refactor the
workloads to get these metrics.
It all just works.
And the result is that I can see
a live network topology diagram
of the application at runtime.
So as an admin or a
platform engineer,
the Anthos dashboard
is like my co-pilot,
showing me what's
happening with the app.
From this dashboard, I can also
dial into one of these services
to view metrics
and service health.
From there, I can set up service
level objectives, or SLOs,
to ensure that the app
is meeting any required
thresholds for availability
and performance.
Anthos Service Mesh is also
integrated into Google Cloud
Monitoring, so I can
create a single dashboard
to see all the metrics
relevant to the application,
from the app code level,
to database metrics,
all the way down to the
underlying infrastructure.
And because I just migrated
this app from VMs to containers,
these dashboards
are really useful
and will help me figure out
how to right-size my workloads
and set appropriate
resource requests.
Overall, moving existing
workloads into Anthos
helps me gain deep
visibility into this app
at all levels of the stack.
Catch you later, Amr.
AMR AWADALLAH: Thanks, Megan.
This looks great.
However, this is not the end
of the modernization journey.
Modernization is a
continuous journey
to improve your
ability to deliver
a quality solution easier,
faster, and more securely.
After the migration
to Anthos, Demo Bank
is now more secure,
available, and responsive.
But next, they
need to accelerate
the rate with which they
deliver improvements
and innovations to meet the
ever-increasing customer
expectations.
In their case, Demo
Bank wants to expand
its online capabilities and
serve more lines of business.
To do this, we can adopt a
microservices architecture
versus two-tier so that we can
scale out just the parts that
need it, and featured teams
can own individual services
to release more
quickly and frequently.
To help with this
modernization journey,
Google Cloud provides
end-to-end development tooling
which allows you to focus
on your business logic,
and automation takes care of
filling in the rest for you.
Furthermore, you can
iterate more quickly
with the confidence of
knowing that automated
observability will detect
production issues early
for you.
Let's now talk to Daniel,
a Software Engineer
working on Spring Boot
integrations for Google Cloud,
and see how we can
quickly develop
a new microservice using
tools that you are already
familiar with.
DANIEL ZOU: (QUIETLY)
Thank you, Amr.
So to modernize--
AMR AWADALLAH: Hey,
Daniel, we can't hear you.
Try this mic.
DANIEL ZOU: Oh.
Thank you, Amr.
So to modernize our
application, let's try
refactoring the authentication
features of Demo Bank
to a separate microservice.
This area of our app has
experienced a lot of growth
and increased traffic.
Normally, this task
would be complex,
but we're going
to take advantage
of a variety of Google
Cloud-managed services
for less maintenance
and better availability,
and also use various tools to
make use of Cloud much easier.
For the new
microservice, we will
use Cloud SQL for our
database, and we'll
configure it for
high availability
with the click of a button.
Next, let's start
writing some code.
Our development team uses Java
and prefers the Spring Boot
framework.
We'll create a Spring Boot
service from start.spring.io
to generate some starter
code for this project.
Select GCP Support
as a dependency,
which allows us to
easily integrate
with Google Cloud services.
Now as we write code,
we're able to just focus
on the business logic.
There will be some
points where we
can leverage more cloud services
in addition to the database.
For example, we
use a private key
to encrypt
authentication tokens.
Previously, this key was stored
in an on-premises secret store
like HashiCorp Vault.
On Google Cloud,
you can continue to use Vault if
you need to, but for this demo,
we'll switch to Google
Secrets Manager, which
is a secure way of storing
secrets on the cloud
so you don't have to manage
the infrastructure yourself.
We can use Spring Cloud GCP
libraries to access the secret
through the application's
configuration
without any extra code.
Spring Cloud GCP is one of
the many libraries and tools
maintained by Google
in partnership
with the open-source community.
Also, as part of the
modernization effort,
we'll trace service calls,
have centralized logging,
and generate custom metrics.
Using Spring Cloud GCP,
all of these features
can be added to our app
through configuration alone.
So this is the big idea.
We don't have to write any
extra code to do all this.
And with minimal
configuration, you can now
see in-application
traces in Cloud Trace,
and clicking Show Logs will
show you the logs associated
with each request.
You can also see JVM and
application-level metrics
exported to Cloud Monitoring
and explore them in a dashboard.
Now because our application
has no custom code
to access Google
Cloud Services, it's
portable across
hybrid environments.
If you need to deploy the
same application on-premises,
simply change the configuration
without modifying the code.
And similarly, an
on-premises application
can easily adopt
Google Cloud Services
through just configuration.
Let's test everything
before we shift it.
For Cloud SQL, to start the
post-stress SQL instance
with data for
testing, we can use
a third-party open-source
project called Test Containers.
Now the database
container is automatically
started when we run
an integration test.
For cloud databases such as
Firestore or Cloud Spanner,
you can use our local emulators.
We'll use a tool called Jib
to containerize our Java
application.
Another alternative
is a buildpack which
can achieve a similar outcome.
These tools let you
use best practices
without needing deep
expertise in container tools.
Let's also run our application
locally to test it out.
I can easily do this with
the Cloud Code extension
in either IntelliJ
or VS Code IDE
and launch the entire
stack in Minikube
so I can see everything working
end-to-end on my local machine.
If I make a change
to the code now,
Cloud Code will automatically
redeploy my changes
into the local environment.
All right, everything
looks good.
I'm ready to check in
the code and see how
it gets pushed to production.
Back to you, Amr.
AMR AWADALLAH: Thanks, Daniel.
That was awesome.
As Daniel showed
you, Google Cloud
provides comprehensive
end-to-end development
tooling, namely, IDE
extensions, integrations
with widely used frameworks, and
fully managed cloud services.
This significantly
accelerates your productivity
so you can realize the true
potential of application
modernization while using skills
and tools you already know
and have.
So what's next?
It looks like we're ready to
deploy Daniel's new service
into our Anthos environment.
Google Cloud is here
to help you with that.
As we increase the number
of Demo Bank services,
it's important that we build
consistency and automation
in our processes.
This is where our continuous
integration and deployment
commonly known as
CI/CD comes in.
CI/CD helps you to quickly,
confidently, and safely
roll out updates for
many services in peril.
This means you can innovate with
lower risk and higher velocity.
Let's bring Megan
back to show you
how Google Cloud supports
you to release new services
in a secure and low-risk way.
Hi, Megan.
Before you start,
have some more coffee.
MEGAN O'KEEFE: Ah.
Thank you, Amr.
Now let's take a look
at Daniel's pull request
in the Demo Bank repository.
The repo uses GitHub Actions
for continuous integration.
Here on Daniel's branch, we
have integration and functional
tests running to make sure
that Daniel's code changes are
compatible with the
other Demo Bank APIs.
Once I review Daniel's code,
I can go ahead and hit Merge.
Doing this will automatically
trigger a release pipeline
running in Google Cloud Build.
This pipeline builds the
Demo Bank container images,
then uses Binary Authorization
to sign all the images.
This helps us ensure that any
container image deployed to GKE
is safe and trusted.
Once this pipeline completes,
another Cloud Build pipeline
starts up.
This is our continuous
deployment pipeline,
which takes the release
deployment manifests,
configured with
the new image tags,
and applies it to the
production GKE cluster.
Then from our development
Slack channel,
Cloud Build sends
us a notification
that the new service has
successfully deployed.
Now that the
container is running,
I can control how traffic
gets sent to this new service
to ensure a safe roll-out.
Because the existing
account service is still
serving requests,
I'm going to keep it
running in the cluster for now.
But I can use Service Mesh
to rewrite HTTP requests
from the account
service monolith
to the new user service
with no code changes
and, on top of that, send
only a small percentage
of that traffic to
Daniel's user service.
Then I can return to the
Anthos Service Mesh dashboard
to view metrics for how
the user service is faring
in production, then
incrementally send more traffic
to it once I know it's healthy.
I can even take
it a step further
and configure security
policies for this new service.
Anthos Config
Management is a tool
that allows you to push
policy configuration to a Git
repository and automatically
sync those policies down
to your clusters.
This can help you
apply org-wide policies
across many services at once.
Because we're dealing with
a banking application,
data security is
really important.
So one thing I can
do is create a policy
to encrypt all HTTP traffic
across all the Demo Bank
workloads.
Once Anthos Config Management
syncs this policy from Git,
I can return to the
Service Mesh dashboard
to see the encryption status
for all of our services.
Here I can now see that traffic
to Daniel's new user service
is encrypted with mutual
TLS authentication.
So that's how I use Google
Cloud to put a new service
into production on Anthos.
Over to you, Amr.
AMR AWADALLAH: Thanks,
Megan, for showing us
the CI/CD process for
Demo Bank services.
I think this is super
cool for several reasons.
First, it's really compelling
how safety and risk reduction
are top of mind throughout
the entire release process.
We ensure the safety of
the deployment itself,
its ability to serve
traffic without errors,
and the authenticity
of the release artifact
through Binary Authorization.
Second, notice how the
automation supported
by cloud-builds, GitHub
Actions, and Anthos policies
help build that safety.
Automation reduces human
input, which, in turn, reduces
the possibility of human error.
This allows us to deploy new
code changes several times
per day, confident that, for
instance, user data encryption
will automatically
be maintained.
A very key point
of this entire talk
is that safety speeds up
innovation and increases
room for creativity.
Now that we're here, we
are in a good position
to take advantage of more
of what Google Cloud offers.
In this case, let's see
what machine learning
can do for our financial
services workloads.
Let's call Sara.
SARA ROBINSON: High, Amr.
Having our application
and data in Google Cloud
allows us to easily tap into
other parts of our platform.
In our app, finding a way to
flag fraudulent transactions
quickly will save everyone
a lot of time and money.
Machine learning is
a great fit for this.
I'll use BigQuery, AutoML
Tables, and AI Platform
Notebooks to build
our solution, and I'll
use the explainability
tools in AutoML
to understand how our model
is making predictions.
As a data scientist, I'd like
to do my data pre-processing
from a notebook environment
where I can interact directly
with BigQuery data.
I'll do this with Cloud
AI Platform Notebooks.
We're using a publicly
available BigQuery data
set of credit card transactions
to train our model.
For each transaction, we have
data on the time, amount,
and a few other variables.
We see that the original data
set is heavily imbalanced,
which could negatively affect
the quality of our model.
To reduce the imbalance,
I'm using a technique
called downsampling to
take all of the examples
from our minority class,
fraud, and a random sample
of our majority
class, while still
maintaining a diverse sample
of the non-fraud data.
Next, I am saving
the updated data
set to a new BigQuery table.
This data is now ready
to be sent to a model.
To build, train, and deploy our
model, I'll use AutoML Tables.
It will let me do
all of these things
without writing any model code.
With AutoML Tables, I
can train an ML model
while keeping my
data in BigQuery.
When I press Train,
AutoML takes care
of transforming our data
into the correct format
and finding the best
model type for our tasks.
Fortunately, AutoML has
some optimization methods
to handle the remaining data
imbalance after downsampling.
Here I'm choosing to optimize
our model's performance
on our less common
class during training.
Now that our model is trained,
let's look at some evaluation
metrics.
The confusion matrix
tells us the percentage
from each class that our
model predicted correctly.
This model reached 86% accuracy
with no false positives
on our fraud class, which
is looking pretty good.
Rather than writing our own
algorithm of hard-coded rules
for catching fraudulent
transactions,
we built a model to do this by
finding patterns in our data.
Even with a
high-quality model, it's
important to understand what
led our model to predict fraud.
Through the Explainable AI
integration with AutoML Tables,
we can see which features
our model is relying
on most to make a prediction.
I can now deploy my
model with one click,
then I can get
predictions in a UI
or with the AutoML
Prediction API.
Let's try it out.
[MYSTERIOUS MUSIC PLAYING]
We'll make a transaction
with this credit card
and see if our model
flags it as fraud.
Looks like this is not
a real credit card.
Yikes.
Oh, wait.
This is a banking demo,
not a baking demo.
Let's go back to the code.
I'm making a request to the
AutoML Tables Prediction API
for my notebook to get a
test prediction on our model
with feature attributions.
In the API response, we
get the model's prediction
and the instance-level
attribution
values indicating which features
our model relied on most
to make this prediction.
From my notebook's
instance, I can
create a new version of the data
set and even programmatically
kick off model retraining.
Let's train our
model for more time
and see if AutoML is able
to create a better model.
In addition to testing our
deployed model from a notebook,
we also want to get
predictions from our web app.
We want to keep the
client code simple
and handle calling the model
and parsing the prediction
response on the server.
I'll take the Python code
that calls our deployed model
and put it in Cloud Run.
Cloud Run lets me take
code in any language
and deploy it in a scalable
container environment
without worrying about
infrastructure management.
With two commands, I can deploy
the container to Cloud Run
so that it's triggered
whenever a transaction is
made from our banking app.
As we iterate on our
Python code and model,
we can also make use of Cloud
Run's traffic splitting feature
to serve new versions
of our service
to a small percentage of users.
To test out my
Cloud Run service,
I'm making a curl
request to it here.
Although the
service is deployed,
I'm only charged for the time
it's being used since Cloud Run
supports auto-scaling
by default.
This means it'll scale to zero
when there are no requests.
And just like that, from data
pre-processing in BigQuery
to a deployed
AutoML Tables model,
we built an end-to-end
fraud detection solution.
With the right tools,
machine learning really
is a piece of cake.
Would you like some, Amr?
AMR AWADALLAH: Thanks, Sara.
That cake looks delicious.
I can't wait to taste it.
That was very impressive.
We just saw how Sara
applied fraud detection
to our financial
services scenario
using tools she already knows.
I believe that every industry
could innovate around
the kind of cloud
scale data analytics
and machine learning made
easily available to your data
engineers, data
scientists, and analysts.
Also, stepping back, as
Megan and Daniel showed you,
we are bringing to dev
and ops an integrated
set of automated capabilities
that represent the best of what
Google has learned
about code, workloads,
and tooling over many
years while developing
our own planet-scale
consumer services.
The end result is that we make
you as productive as possible
while improving the
quality of your software
and enabling faster and
safer release rates.
We bring this to you through
your favorite open-source
on third-party frameworks,
enterprise applications, tools,
and languages, meeting
you where you are,
so you can start solving
immediately with the skills
and code you really have.
You saw Megan use
Anthos and Cloud Build
to deploy and operate
containerized applications
in a safe, predictable way.
This means developers
can focus more
on the application logic
versus the infrastructure,
allowing them to iterate
at a faster rate.
You saw Daniel use Spring
Boot and Spring Cloud GCP
to set up tracing,
logging, and monitoring
with only configuration changes.
This also means
that your code is
portable to any cloud provider
on-premises or the Edge.
And you saw Sara
go from raw data
to a trained,
deployed AutoML model
all without moving
data from BigQuery.
This means you can train
high-quality models with less
code, allowing you to focus
on improving the predictions
and getting them faster
to your end users.
To learn more, we have the
Google Cloud Certification
Program, which allows you to
specialize in our products
in an industry-recognized way.
We also have our
YouTube channel, blogs,
and online tutorials authored
by many of our engineers
at Google.
Whether you are already using
Google Cloud or just starting,
I hope we have inspired
you on your application,
modernization, and data-powered
innovation journey.
We are so excited to
be working with you.
Let's get solving.
Now I can finally enjoy some
of Sara's delicious cake.
JULIA PEROMINGO: Hi there.
This is a dev video.
CHUKA OFILI: And I'm here to
tell you a very short story.
JOAO ROMAO: How GCP has
made my life easier--
take one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANTONIO CACHUAN: Cloud Run
only takes five minutes
to have my solution deployed.
KALEV LEETARU: BigQuery makes
it possible to understand,
analyze, and even forecast
our world at planetary scale.
JAYASHREE RAVI:
--GCP's Dataproc.
It was not only having all the
applications that I needed,
but it was extremely easy to
fire up a stack in the Cloud
within a few seconds.
CHUKA OFILI: I once had to
set up a Kubernetes cluster,
and it took me two whole days to
get everything up and running.
Now when I moved to
Google Kubernetes Engine,
it just took me two minutes.
JULIA PEROMINGO: I really
do love the Cloud Shell.
It's so easy that you can
focus on what you want to do.
ROB LEGGETT: Since receiving
the Google Professional Solution
Architect Certification,
I was able to help solve
for our analytics problems.
KELVIN WU: I cannot imagine if
we had to build everything from
scratch.
AI SUGIO: AutoML Vision
Edge [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: You
can unleash your creativity
by using what you want
and what you like.
JOAO ROMAO: Making a
complex task be simple.
NAOTO KAMIYAMA: Google
Cloud [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE:
It's absolutely magic.
JULIA PEROMINGO: OK, so thanks.
ROB LEGGETT: Thanks.
CHUKA OFILI: OK, we've come
to the end of my story.
So roll credits now.
Bye.